bonjour aurélien véron et merci d'être
en direct avec nous ce matin sur rtl
france alors vous dénoncez une
évacuation
précipiter une décision qui n'a pas qui
a été décidé finalement sans
concertation avec les élus de la sainte
anne est
absolument et les élus et les ailes et
20 la seine saint denis vont connaître
les mêmes déboires que les riverains
parisiens qui subissent ces déplacements
improvisé cette guerre entre la mairie
de paris et la préfecture de police
entrera nidal go emmanuel macron d'une
certaine manière c'est à dire que la
mairie prend des choix arbitraires sans
prévenir à prévenir la police par
exemple de déplacer les cra que de la
colline du crack ou d'autres quartiers
vers le jardin d'eole la nuit la
préfecture de police s'est exprimé pour
désapprouver ce choix de la mairie de
paris donc ça entre l'absence de
concertation et puis maintenant la
préfecture de police des places ces
toxicomanes à la porte de paris tout
près de la seine saint denis sans
prévenir la mairie de paris et on a
entendu des adjoints notamment le
logement la santé de la mairie de paris
attaquer la fermeture de police en
disant que c'était une décision qui
était inhumaine scandaleuse donc on voit
bien qu'il ya une guerre politique à la
prochaine présidentielle c'est pas
anodin et que les habitants de la
seine-saint-denis comme de paris sont
les victimes de cette guerre qui a une
connotation clairement politique est ce
que vous savez pourquoi justement avoir
choisi cet endroit alors qu' il y à
d'autres endroits qui existent avec des
configurations à similaires notamment
dans l'ouest parisien
je connais pas le détail de ce choix la
préfecture de police ne forme pas les
élus de ces décisions et même la mairie
de taille vous savez qu'on ait lieu
conseil de paris on n'a pas beaucoup
d'information de la mairie elle même
donc tout ça est assez opaque je crois
que ça traduit l'absence de stratégies
pour traiter cette addiction vous savez
le crack c'est la double peine c'est à
la fois une maladie pour les cracks ceux
qui sont des personnes malades et qui ne
sont pas traitées correctement parce
qu'on ne peut pas les hommes vers les
entasser haut dans le jardin d'eole la
nuit ou les mettre à la porte de paris
ça va pas régler leur addiction ça va
pas régler leur maladie leur traitement
leur famille sont dévastés voit bien
qu'on les laisse à la rue sans soins
donc ce ne sont pas des soins qu'on leur
propose ses les déplacés les repousser
en fonction des gènes et des enjeux plus
politique la deuxième peine c'est que
les riverains les premières victimes de
ce déplacement quand vous avez des
cracks eux en bas de chez vous et moi
j'suis allé voir les jardins d'eole pour
constater l'ambiance vous avez des
zombies c'est vraiment des personnes qui
sont malades profondément avec souvent
des troubles psychiatriques qui se
traînent dans la rue qui parfois sont
agressifs ont des comportements intro
inattendue on a vu un malade un
toxicomane taper sur une poussette et un
bébé se prendre donc un coût et avec un
visage tuméfié après des gens en
terrasse de bistrot qui se prennent tout
d'un coup un sac dans la figure donc ce
sont des gens qui sont imprévisibles et
qu'il faut soigner aujourd'hui la
méthode qui est de les trimballer d'un
endroit à l'autre et de donc de
pénaliser les riverains est une méthode
de à la petite semaine qui n'est pas à
la hauteur de l'onj long jeu c'est un
enjeu sanitaire et c'est toxicomanes
doivent être traités par des
désintoxication de longue durée
peut-être dans des centres fermés pour
certains d'entre eux avec des
psychiatres pour traiter leurs oeufs
d'or pour leurs troubles psychiatriques
horizon non en tout cas c'est pas en les
chassant d'un quartier à l'autre iron
ont pourri sans l'avis des riverains
qu'on a réglé ce problème alors vous
demander à être reçus à matignon pour en
discuter justement avec le premier
ministre jean castex mais toutefois le
ministre l'intérieur gérald darmanin a
déclaré hier qu'une réunion aurait lieu
demain justement sous l'autorité du
préfet de la région ile de france avec
le préfet de police de paris est ainsi
que les élu es qu'est ce que vous
attendez de cette réunion demain
écoutez rachida dati la présidente du
groupe changer paris attend que l'état
prenne ses responsabilités et n'accable
pas ni les parisiens ni les habitants de
seine-saint-denis c'est à dire encore
une fois de prendre en considération
cette maladie grave profond tragique
pour les familles pour les aides les
toxicomanes ou même et pour les
riverains et donc ouvre des centres
dédiés à cette maladie toxicomane du
crack le crack c'est pas d'héroïne 1 c
c'est la cocaïne base et c'est vraiment
un autre produit et cesse de trouver des
petites et des espèces de patch inutile
et ruineux comme les salles de
consommation à moindre risque les
fameuses salles de shoot qui en fait ne
font que inciter les toxicomanes à
poursuivre leur addiction dans un cadre
un peu plus chaleureux mais qui n'est
pas du tout adapté à leur pathologie le
rapport parlementaire qui vient de
sortir et qui a étudié donc les
différents modèles de salles de
consommation à moindre risque en europe
et à strasbourg constatent des résultats
plutôt positifs lorsqu'on parle de
toxicomane à l'héroïne le crack
visiblement ça ne marche pas donc ces
salles de shoot pur dekra que pour des
toxicomanes addict au crack ce n'est pas
une solution et la mairie de paris est
en train de vouloir multiplier dans la
ville de paris donc ça c'est non il faut
tout de suite qu'on s'oppose à ce genre
de solution qui n'est qu'ils sont des
solutions qui ne sont pas du tout
efficace qui sont coûteuses qui sont un
massacre pour le quartier les habitants
de lariboisière dans 10ème
arrondissement à paris sont témoins tous
les jours deux bagarres d'agression il
ya eu même un viol enfin c'est une
catastrophe pour les habitants pour les
enfants qui doivent heureux passés à
côté de cesser ces toxicomanes qui sont
parfois à moitié nue qui défèquent dans
la rue sans semble totalement désinhibé
on a vraiment affaire à des gens qui
sont malades donc il faut que l'état
entende la voix de la raison c'est à
dire le traitement du crack ça passe par
des centres psychiatriques des centres
de désintoxication des centres fermés
pour les cas les plus graves sont les
gens qui sont vraiment qu'ils ont perdu
leur lors leur conscience de manière à
les sortir de cette addiction c'est la
seule solution il est laissé dans
l'arène sera que nous fera qu'empirer la
situation
très bien en tout cas merci merci
beaucoup aurélien véron d'avoir répondu
à nos questions jours avec vous est
conseillé de paris un porte parole du
groupe changez paris